each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
morning everyone I'm tasty cannon I'm a
seeker compliance strategist however I
was recently in the corporate privacy
group and I hosted a lot of these
speakers that were so happy and lucky to
get to come to Microsoft a lorry crane
is the last one that I amex you going
representing the external privacy
research program is now going to be
turned over to Brendan Brendan Lynch
these are a directory privacy strategy
and corporate privacy group if you go to
our MS our privacy website on MSR or
through the privacy site you notice a
list of researches we have there are
internal and external Microsoft and of
course once again we're fortunate to
have well let me list the one to the
internal first so this shows all of our
privacy researchers entering their names
with their email addresses there are
department with a link to their
Department information and then a link
to their personal site that some
research that microsoft com and there's
also a list of external privacy
researchers and I did get their
permission before posting their public
information or personal information and
there is Laurie and it's like Laurie so
if you want to converse with her you can
just click on her email address and send
her an email and say hey what's up with
p3p these days
one of the most important things know
about Laura she is the mother of p3p she
also wrote the book on p 3 p which is
still for sale i think pricey group
still has a few copies signed copies
left I'd also like to give a special
thanks to Lori for participating all
these years not only in this privacy
research program but our trustworthy
computing academic advisory board Laura
if you could come up and accept this
award thank you for your support for all
the years thank you yeah without further
ado I'd like to introduce dr. lori
greiner well thanks and thanks to all of
you who came in early this morning uh
sorry for 9am but i have a1 p.m. flight
to catch back to the east coast so
that's why it had to be that way so
before I launch into the main part of my
talk on privacy I just want to tell you
a little bit about the lab that I have
at CMU and some of the things that we're
doing so i started when i got to CMU
about two and a half years ago the CMU
usable privacy and security lab known as
cups and we focus on usability issues in
both privacy and security systems the
number of students and other faculty who
are working together with the lab and
there's a book which I co-edited with
Simpson garfinkel last year which came
out recently on security and usability
and it has papers from about 60
researchers in the field so some of the
things that my lab is doing right now so
we're doing a lot on privacy policies
which is what I'm going to talk to you
about today we're also doing work on a
project we call supporting trust
decisions and here we're looking at the
kinds of
trust decisions that the typical user is
asked to make on a regular basis so I
get this email as an attachment should I
open it email says it's coming from my
bank is it really from my bank those
sorts of decisions and we're focused on
the human aspect of it and what can we
do so that the users are not fooled by
things that that are trying to get them
we're also looking at privacy and
usability and pervasive computing
environments and one of the things we
have going right now is this phone that
I have I can use to actually unlock the
door to my office we have Bluetooth door
locks and we have this whole crypto
system where we have to demonstrate to
the door with a proof that is allowed to
open the credentials are our past with
the phones what's really interesting is
not so much that I can get into my
office this way but that a student could
be standing outside my office with their
phone and I'm here they could SMS me and
say can I get into your office and I
could decide to let them in just now or
for the next day or for the next week or
whatever sort of credential I want to
send back to their phone so that they
could get in so we've been looking at
the the the usability aspect of this and
you know now that most of the crypto
work is done how do we set this up so
that you know my secretary can
understand how to use this and we're
also looking at use cases for the system
and we we right now have about 18 people
in the building who have these phones
and have access to it and we interview
them on a monthly basis and we notice
things like sometimes it's easier to
just hand somebody your phone than to go
through this hole SMS thing and what can
we do to make it so that they'll
actually do what they're supposed to do
anyway so we're having fun with that and
and that's us related to the smartphones
were the other thing that we're doing
with with the phones is friend finder
locate location finding services but
trying to focus in on how can I actually
control the privacy aspects of it so you
know sometimes I'll allow people to find
me and sometimes I won't and I'd like to
set up rules for doing that but I don't
want to spend hours right writing
privacy rules so how can we make this
all work
seamlessly and we're also looking at
usable anonymity tools so we've been
working with there's a tour anonymity
system which the Electronic Frontier
Foundation is sponsoring and they had a
contest to develop a graphical user
interface for it and so we had a team of
students and faculty work on that and we
we won the first run competition so here
we all are with our tour t-shirts on
after that okay so so we're going to
talk about privacy today and I assume
most of you are here because you already
have some interest in privacy but just
in case you need some some a testimonial
as to the importance of privacy Britney
Spears let us all know a few weeks ago
so she says that you have to realize
that privacy is one of these things we
all need as human beings so now you're
convinced right all right so if we need
privacy then we need privacy policies
right well no the the idea behind
privacy policies was that this is a way
that companies can communicate about
their privacy practices with people and
particularly on the Internet companies
are communicating about their their
online privacy policies and so when you
go to a website the theory is is that
you can find out what data there what
they're going to collect what they're
going to do with it and you can make an
informed decision about whether you want
to interact with a particular website
that's the theory anyway there's some
other things about privacy policies
which are useful so in the United States
where we have minimal privacy
legislation the fact that we have a
privacy policy makes companies subject
to regulation by the Federal Trade
Commission because the Federal Trade
Commission is allowed to regulate for
fraud and deceptive practices so as soon
as I put up a policy and say this is
what I'm going to do then if I fail to
actually comply with my own policy it's
fraud and then the FTC can come after me
not because i violated a privacy law but
because of the fraud issue so so the
Federal Trade Commission um at the end
of the 1990s was really trying to twist
the arms of lots
companies and say you have to put up
these privacy policies and somewhat
amazingly I think most of them did so
they went from you know almost nobody
having website privacy policies to
something like ninety-five percent of
commercial websites having privacy
policies in the course of just a few
years right but there are a lot of
problems with privacy policies people
find them very difficult to read people
find them difficult to understand their
long they're time-consuming and then you
finally get through you've read this
whole long thing you think you figure it
out and there's this line that says it's
subject to change without notice so you
wonder how do I have to do this again
every time I come back to this website
and so they're somewhat problematic and
at the end of the day we find out that
although people say they like privacy
policies and they get warm fuzzy
feelings about websites because they see
that link that says privacy policy
almost nobody actually reads them and so
from the perspective of informing
consumers they turn out to not be very
effective so the World Wide Web
Consortium decided to try to do
something about this by developing a
standard XML format for privacy policies
and this the this was conceived back in
1995 and basically the Federal Trade
Commission said to the industry there
must be something you can do about these
privacy policies and make them useful to
people and there was an industry group
that got together with some consumer
groups and the world wide web consortium
and they said well what could we do and
they came up with this idea of let's
have a system so people can have their
browser negotiate with websites about
privacy and it was mostly lawyers who
came up with this initial idea and I
think they really envision your browser
handling with the website the website
would say hey I want your name address
and phone number and I want to sell it
to everybody and your browser would say
oh no you can't do that i'll tell you
what i'll give you my zip code it's not
enough and it could go back and forth
that I i think they some of these people
really envisioned that
that that's what we were going to do and
so w3c adopted a working group to to
actually try to build this thing and we
spent several years working on that
larger vision of the tagging browser
before we realized that it was it just
wasn't going to happen that that there
were there were technical reasons but
there were also policy and business
reasons that it's so difficult for a
company to come up with one privacy
policy they can stand behind imagine
them coming up with five that they could
negotiate over you know so for many
reasons that this whole haggling thing
wasn't going to happen and so what we
ended up with after five years in w3c
working on this with basically XML
syntax for privacy policies and some
conventions and protocols so that we
know where to actually find the policies
and actually get them sent where they
need to go at the right time um and so
so w3c specified all of this but the
policy is still not useful unless
there's some user agent that can do
something useful with it and w3c doesn't
say much about user agents they left
that up for somebody else to figure out
and so we saw the first p3p user agents
were built into ie6 and Netscape seven
and we got some some initial adoption of
p3p so in case you haven't seen it this
is what p3p looks like in ie6 there's
this little eyeball with a do not enter
sign symbol which i think is probably
one of the least understood parts of ie6
I know often when I when I talk to
audiences I I asked you know anybody can
anybody tell me what this means and
usually nobody has any idea what it
means some people vaguely remember
having seen it some people are swear
they've never seen it even though they
use ie6 the first time it appeared there
was an explanation but that was a long
time ago and people swat it away and
then there's this a settings menu that
lets you actually control your privacy
settings
and most people have no idea that that
exists either but if they do they read
it and they try to understand what it
means and it's fairly cryptic so the
average person doesn't know what a
third-party cookie is a compact privacy
policy and then then here's one I love
that even privacy experts have trouble
with what does it mean to do something
without implicit consent think about
that one without implicit consent I I
thought about it quite a bit and then I
think I asked JC I don't know it he said
I didn't write it I don't know oh and
something new would opt out and opt-in
and but anyway the point is that that
this p3p implementation here could could
use a lot of improvement some other
things about it if you actually click on
that little eyeball thing you get a list
of all the cookies on a web page and
what ie6 decided to do with them and so
in this case there are three cookies
that decided to block them and then we
can actually click on them and if the
cookies came from a p3p enabled web site
then we can get information about the
privacy policy there's also a well
hidden feature in the view menu the view
privacy report feature now is anybody in
here use that feature alright so here we
have you like one or two in a normal
audience at zero but but this has been
in here ever since I e6 came out five
years ago or whenever it was this has
been in here if you go to the View menu
and you select privacy report what it
does is it goes to the website it
fetches that XML privacy policy it
translates it into English and it
displays it here for you and it's I'm
told it's actually internationalized so
that you know if you have the French
version of the browser displays it in
French or whatever language is
appropriate so it this is nice that we
get this automatic translation you might
be able to tell from the size of the
scroll bar that it's a very lengthy
translation it's quite verbose and
unfortunately it's not a hundred percent
accurate because there's a bug in it
and that legs been there for five years
too but it's a nice start on a p3p user
agent netscape has something very
similar instead of a slider bar they've
got the little radio buttons but it's
essentially the same same deal instead
of the eyeball symbol when when the
netscape the first version investigates
having came out they had a chocolate
chip cookie and the nice thing about the
chocolate chip cookie is that you see it
and you go cookie it has something to do
with cookies and so that's really good
because I balls don't have anything to
do with cookies the problem is is that
it's supposed to be a warning symbol and
you know unless you're like on a diet or
something you can't be too scared of a
chocolate chip cookie right so so that
wasn't too effective either and so in
subsequent releases of nets gate 7 they
switched to an eyeball symbol isn't it's
not the same eyeball symbol is that IE
has but but it's a similar eyeball
symbol I think it's an eyeball with it
with a piece of paper instead of a do
not enter side but um I mean anyway so
apparently eyeballs are supposed to mean
that this website has some privacy issue
but nobody understands that ok and
Netscape also will give you a summary of
the of the compact p3p policy that comes
with the cookie so it's kind of a short
version of the privacy policy so instead
of that long thing that you had a scroll
through the scroll bar they give you
this little short thing they also have a
way of getting the long thing and there
is this actually anna format that's not
quite as long as the IE 61 it has nice
bolded list but they seem to have
forgotten to run it through a spell
checker and a grammar checker and so
there's a little weird too so when I was
the chair of the p3p working group and
we saw these user agents and we we poked
a lot of fun at them and then we said
we'd like you know something better and
and so everybody said well you build
something better and I was at 80 where
we didn't have a browser but I convinced
the powers that be that that they could
let us build a plug-in for a browser and
so we built this browser helper object
for ie6 that would be a piece
p user agent and when i left ATT they
eventually released this is open source
and so my students are continuing to
work on it so we called it privacy bird
and we didn't actually worried about the
cookie part because if you're using IE 6
that's already handling the the blocking
cookies based on p 3 p what we were
interested is more of the informing the
user about privacy part and so we have a
persistent icon in the form of a bird
which you can look at to understand a
website's privacy policy so here you can
see in the upper right-hand corner there
is our green privacy burn this is
actually the second version on the soul
of you who've seen privacy bird before
might notice that the bird has changed
but so we have we have the green bird
there and it will tweet at us maybe we
can't hear the sound okay the sound the
sound is some is going on the video but
we don't have it in the room alright so
trust me it tweets at you I have the
green happy bird this indicates that
this website matches the privacy
preferences that I have set up in my
browser here we have a a site with a red
angry bird that does not match the
preferences that I've set up in the
browser and when I mouse over that red
bird I get that little pop-up box there
which tells me exactly what the
difference is between my settings and
the websites policy and if I click on
the bird I can get a summary of the
privacy policy so this is where we take
the XML translate it back into English
and we when we designed us we like to
think about it as a nutrition label for
privacy so we were looking for a kind of
a standard format that would be really
easy to see at a glance what the privacy
practices are but there are a lot of
privacy practices and it's long and so
what we ended up doing was having a
summary here that kind of unfold so you
can drill down and get more detailed
information so what we do is we put at
the top the reasons that the policy
doesn't match our preferences because
that's probably the first thing
somebody's going to want to know when
they see
redbird and we hyperlinked the opt outs
so if I see it doesn't match my
preferences but this thing that I don't
like there's a way to opt out of it all
I have to do is click here and it will
take me to a page on the website that
tells me about opt out um what I have
too much she provided link right so I in
a p3p policy if a website declares that
opt out is available they have to
provide a URL where they explain it now
it may not be an online opt-out it may
it may explain call this 800 number but
they have to at least explain how to do
it and put that in there p 3 p policy
those like saturday um they're sometimes
out of date there they don't appear to
be out of date as often as the email
address for the chief privacy officer
without of date oh that that one seems
to be out of date a lot these tend to
once once a website has put them up they
tend not to move this page around that
much but but they're not they're not
always up to date okay another thing
you'll see here is that the next thing
we put is this red box that tells you
how the company will share your
information and the reason we've done
that is because we've done a lot of
studies where we ask people about what
they're interested in in privacy
policies and one of the things that it
comes up very frequently as people say
well I want to know if the company is
going to sell my information who they're
going to share it with so we said okay
let's pull that out and put that right
up front okay now if you scroll down we
get to the part where we see more
detailed information about what data
they collect and what they're going to
do with it and then you can open up
these little triangles and get even more
detail where we can actually enumerate
the kinds of data is collected if
they've declared that and have a lot
more information okay another thing that
privacy bird does is it checks for
embedded content so as you know a web
page is composed of many different
objects it has images and frames and
sounds and they're not all served from
the same web server and so there may be
multiple privacy policies that actually
apply to a page and this is something
that a human inspecting the page is not
going to notice unless they get into
view source and start looking at it
very carefully so privacy bird actually
goes and checks all those objects and it
should be associated p3p policies so in
this case we can bring up the all the
objects on the page and you can see
there quite a few objects on this page
and they come from many different
servers and we've checked the privacy
policies on all of those objects and
some of them matched our preferences
some of them don't match and some of
them don't have p3p policy so it's
unknown and then you could if you want
to actually click on one of those
policies and bring up the policy summary
for any of those this is to show you
what the privacy settings actually look
like there are are many many fields in
the XML and so you could have a huge
number of different fine grain settings
if you wanted to in p3p we initially
were exploring this big
multi-dimensional matrix and that wasn't
going to work so our goal here with the
design interface that that would fit on
one screen and so we could only have as
many questions which would fit on one
screen which is 12 in this case and we
found that some users like that and we
found some users thought that 12 was
still too many so then we added low
medium and high and you know if you
don't want to read through any of this
you can just pick low medium and high
and when you pick one of those it
automatically checks the appropriate
boxes so you can actually see what low
medium and high mean and then if you say
oh I like medium but i want to add this
one more you can just go ahead and
modify that setting you can also import
settings and export settings so if you
want to take somebody else's settings
and in the import feature you can
actually adjust settings that are not on
this screen is there are many other
fields and p3p that these settings don't
eat don't even touch but if you use
there's a there's a language called
Appel which is an XML language of use
that you can actually touch all the
settings that way so let me show you an
example of privacy burden use so let's
say I want to send flowers to my mom so
I don't normally send flowers to my mom
so I don't have a favorite florist so I
go to google and I do a search for sin
flowers and 0 1 800 flowers calm that
looks good so let's go to their way and
I have a red bird oh yes yes the Google
sigh had a yellow bird that that's
because Google doesn't have a p3p policy
and i know i've been i've been yelling
at them for years and they just won't
listen yes yes but that is true services
this is yellow but that's great yes so
msn search does have a p3p policy too
we're good but but Google does not and
so we have the yellow bird so any we get
100 flowers and they have a red bird and
i don't i don't really like sites that
don't follow my privacy preferences and
I especially don't want them to violate
my mom's privacy so I'm not going to
order from 1-800 flowers so I go back to
google and i run my search again and
this time we'll try ftd.com and we go
there and they have a yellow bird too
and i'm too lazy to go read their
privacy policy so i guess i have to go
back to google again and keep repeating
repeating and eventually i will either
give up and decide i'm just going to
call my mom and forget the flowers or
I'm going to to order the flowers from
some site regardless of their privacy
policy so there has to be a better way
and that's what we decided to work on so
we developed the tool called privacy
finder and here i can type my search
into privacy finder i can choose whether
i want to run this on the google or the
yahoo search engine the reason we have
google and yahoo there's because they
had their api's exposed in a way that
was very easy for us to do that I don't
know if the if there's an API for the
msn search engine we can use if there is
would be happy to add it on so i can i
pick my search engine I can pick my
preference level and in the preference
level I've got the high medium and low
and if I want to go and answer those 12
questions I can actually go to the
custom settings and do that
air and I search and now I get search
results that are annotated with privacy
information and what we do is we get
back that first 10 search results and we
reorder them so that those with the best
privacy policies are at the top but only
within those 1003 green bars know that
800 floor 1 800 flowers yeah so what
yeah the way you can interpret this is
that if the great it's a it's a privacy
o meter or something like that or Berto
meter who were calling it for a while so
if it has all the boxes filled in then
it's a perfect match with my settings
here we have three out of four filled in
so that means it doesn't match my
settings but it's only off by a little
bit and if we had say just for blank
boxes that would mean it completely
didn't match my settings I mean then
come back to the example and money
hundred florals her flowers part me came
out read that doesn't mean it's a bad
policy it just means it didn't meet your
criteria that's right a red bird could
still be much better than many yes
yellow burger and and in the initial
birth of the privacy finder instead of
these greenboxes we put the birds in and
I'm going to talk about a study we did
and one of the problems was that people
interpreted the red bird as bad but in
fact it all it means is it doesn't match
and and so here's a sight that would get
a red bird but it actually almost
matches and it's a lot better than the
other site in this particular search you
don't see how this but there I could
have done another search that would have
come up with lots of sites with one
green box or no green boxes and that
would be much preferable to that it
seems like we're teaching users two
different things to look for and if a
meter is that are the bird here when
they need every bit of the bird you know
what so this is a recent change where we
went to the meter and we're going to
think about going you know what we
should do in the and the other piece of
software as well but yeah when we're
still actually experimenting with the
meter to see whether people actually
understand it we haven't had the meter
out long enough to be convinced that
it's definitely the right answer but it
seems to be going in the right direction
so in this case I can see right away
here's one that perfectly matches my
privacy practices I can go there and
turn up they have a green bird and I can
order the flowers and be happy so so as
I said this is privacy finder this was
initially developed at AT&T Labs it was
a very very rough prototype that took
you know like two minutes to return
search results and it just it it didn't
have preference settings it it was just
sort of a very rough proof of concept
and so my students completely rewrote it
and now it's very fast that you can have
a choice of search engine you can
generate privacy reports just like
privacy bird does and it's publicly
available you can actually go and try it
today Yolo I have no idea they have a
they have a public API and we're using
it yeah I actually they must be somewhat
ok with it because they did give us a
larger API keys than we normally get
because normally you can only use their
API for like 50 you know search of the
day or something and you know we use
that up pretty quickly so we went back
to them and said could we have you know
ten thousand searches a day or something
and I don't remember what they find they
didn't give us as much as we wanted but
they did give us a much larger key
sponsored links and things right but
that's how their API works there eight
when you use their API it doesn't give
you the sponsored links so but there's
sponsored links back on your page yeah
yeah we've actually we've actually
considered doing that as a way of
raising money for the lab we we have
talked about that and we've been going
back and forth on so on the one hand we
could raise some money that way in the
other hand is supposed to be a privacy
service and so we're you know we're
trying to keep it really clean but yeah
you know actually what we would really
like is for one of these search engines
to like this so much that they would
want to build it into their service and
so we're hopeful that some search engine
it out there will decide they really
like it and so far that hasn't happened
so it's just running on one of our
servers in our lab and it's publicly
available but we're not advertising it
too much because it would obviously
bring down our server if too many people
used it and the the the key to actually
making this run fast turned out to be
the cash so we we didn't really spend a
whole lot of time doing performance
optimization it's a bunch of Perl
scripts and I'm sure we could optimize
it a lot more than how it's currently
done but what really sped it up was the
cash because before we had the cash
every time you do a search you get back
10 results you have to go to 10 websites
and fetch their p3p policies that takes
at least three round trips and even to
find out that they don't have a p3p
policy and so just waiting for that to
happen took a long time and often it's
waiting for timeouts that took a long
time so by caching information about
whether or website has a p3 company
policy and if so what it is that that
saved us a lot of time and the way the
p3 piece back is written you can safely
cash for 24 hours and so we we just have
a process is constantly running and
updating the cash and for a while we
were actually checking every site in our
cash every 24 hours and the thing is
sites don't add p3p policies not fast so
it was using lots and lots of bandwidth
and our network administrators were
yelling at us and so we decided to make
it so if they don't have a p3p policy we
wait 30 days before we check again but
we also have a button on the website for
where somebody can type in a URL and say
update the cache for this URL now and so
if if a company adds a p3p policy they
can do that and will immediately update
our cash for them so yeah so we now have
18,000 p3p policies and we have three
hundred and eighty nine thousand sites
that we are checking and how how did we
get all those sites in the cache so
anytime anybody does a search whatever
the results are we put in the cache but
one of the studies which
talk about in a minute we actually took
twenty thousand search terms and random
to do the study and in the process of
doing the study that built our cash okay
so anyway that's that's what it looks
like and here's another search so an
example we have the mouse over here to
give you the quick information and then
you can get the whole privacy report
here again just like in privacy bird
they're a bunch of new features that
were planning on building so we're
interested in adding price comparison
and I'll show you a screenshot in a
minute of a first version of that we're
we're still sort of refining the privacy
report and trying to make that more
useful for people and we also in the
process of doing this have noticed that
there are a lot of websites that have
errors in there p3p policies and there
are probably a lot of semantic errors
which we can't necessarily catch but but
they're definitely a lot of syntax
errors which we we can very easily catch
and so we're thinking about adding an
interface for a system administrator to
be able to see see what their errors are
in their p30 policy using this tool and
we're also planning on on actually
collecting list of sites with errors and
contacting them and and seeing if we can
get them to fix them and trying to
understand the source of the errors
creation tool no no we don't yeah we've
been using the IBM one okay so here's a
first version of our art shopping p3p
search so here we use the the yahoo
shopping interface and so you can see
not only which sites have the best
privacy policy but also which ones have
the best price as well okay so now that
we've built this we want to know is it
actually useful and there's kind of four
questions that we've come up with that
that speak to whether or not it's useful
alright so the first is do users care is
this even something that people care
about and there seems to be a lot of
survey evidence that people do care
about privacy and so that's not the that
hasn't been the focus of our work we're
going to we're going to
except that from what other people have
said the next question is are there
enough websites that actually use p3p
that this it can be useful because if
you do a search and you don't get any
birds or green boxes then you know
what's the point and so I'm going to
tell you about a study where we looked
at that we also want to know whether
people understand the information that
they get back and as I explained about
you know the misinterpreting what the
red bird means there's there's some
indication that some of these things
need some improvement and we down the
road plan to do a lot more work in that
area and then finally do people do
anything with this information so if
you're doing this search so that you can
purchase something do you actually
change where you're going to make your
purchase based on the information this
gives you and so we're looking at that
as well right so I'm going to focus
right now on two of these questions okay
so website adoption of p3p this is work
that I did with one of my students
there's a gomin and with abdur chowdhury
who is at america online search and what
what we wanted to do was to look at
search the search engine on as as a way
of understanding p3p popularity so there
have been a lot of studies in the past
including some that we've done where you
get the list of the top 500 most popular
websites and you see if they have p3p
but this doesn't show you what the
typical user sees through a search
engine and since we know a lot of users
start their day on the internet with the
search engine that's kind of a lens
through the internet that applies to a
lot of users so we wanted to see well
when you do a search how many p3p
policies come up so we got a list of
20,000 search terms that real AOL users
had typed in they basically took a
week's worth of search logs and randomly
sampled 20,000 gave us that list and
they actually had had some think interns
at AOL categorized the twenty thousand
searches into a number of different
categories as well which was nice
then we used the the frugal search
engine where they list on the front page
recent searches and we screen scrape
that for a while until we got almost a
thousand search terms off of that and so
we had two terms we called the AOL terms
are typical search terms and the other
ones were our e-commerce search terms
because we know if you're doing a frugal
search you want to buy something so then
we took all the search terms and we
submitted them to the google yahoo and
AOL search engines and we collected the
top 20 results at each of those search
engines returned now the AOL search
engine actually is the google search
engine or it's powered by google but it
gets slightly different results
interestingly then we came up with a set
of 5 p-3 p rule sets which you could
think of as different different sets of
privacy preferences that somebody might
have and we ran all the p 3 p policies
that we discovered among those search
results against those five rule sets and
then we saved our annotated search
results in a database and then
separately AOL gave us the 30,000
domains that were most often clicked on
from the AOL search engine and we did we
did the same thing with those domains
okay so here's what we found as far as
the overall deployment of all the sites
that were now in our database after
having having done all this we found
that ten percent of them have p3p or ten
percent of the typical sites have p3p
but the e-commerce search terms led us
to sites that were twice as likely to
have p3p so that indicates that that
among sites that people actually shop at
they're more likely to have p3p than
just the average random site on the
internet okay we also saw that the more
popular a site is the more likely it is
to have p3p so if you look at all of the
sites in our cash overall about five
percent of them have p3p but you start
looking at the most popular sites you
see that you know
you know the top 10 most popular sites
about a third of them have p3p and you
can see that this kind of levels off
down a little bit of above losing the
top 37 so I think it levels off around
eight percent there all right um to give
you an idea of who has p3p policies so
we looked at the sites that came up the
most times in search results using the
typical terms and e-commerce terms and
so these are the ones that had p3p you
can see that that Yahoo is the absolute
top most popular site with p3p no matter
how you slice it part of the reason for
that is that Yahoo is popular but part
of the reason for that is that the Yahoo
privacy policy goes on all yahoo hosted
sites and so there are a lot of
businesses that are hosted by yahoo and
instead of seeing the businesses p3p
policy you see Yahoo's p3p policy
something which I'm not so sure is a
good thing but um that's the way it is
you see there are a few government
websites the national library of
medicine comes up pretty frequently
because when people do health cert
searches NLM is often in the search
results okay so using the categories
that the AOL interns did for us we look
to see whether there are certain
categories of sites that had more p3p
policies yeah too bad guys have p3
policies like spammers affiliates things
like this if some of them do so what is
it all it means is that if you can find
some you consider them for fraud if if
they violated yeah yeah yeah I mean you
can have a p3p policy that says you know
we have a terrible privacy policy you
could also have a p3p policy it says we
have a great great privacy policy and
they'll I have to find the men you have
yeah and that's the same way with the
written privacy policies as well uh
should find much evidence attacks for
mom um no we find a lot of evidence that
people put up p3p policies and forget
about them and don't change them when
they change their privacy policies but
we haven't found a lot of evidence of
people malicious
misleading in the first place okay so
this is the distribution so you can see
that shopping is most likely to have a
p3p policy and pornography is actually
not very likely to have p3p policy and
everything else falls in between ok ok
so we also looked at if I run a search
how likely am I to find a p3p hit in my
top 10 or top 20 search results so if i
look at the top 20 search results
eighty-three percent of the time i'm
going to find at least one site that has
a p3p policy and if i look only at the
top 10 results sixty-eight percent of
the time i'm going to find it and and
that's in the the typical searches
looking again at the typical searches in
the top 20 search results right if I
let's say I'm not happy just finding a
site with a p3p policy I want to site
with a good p3p policy well good is in
the eye of the beholder but we decided
to take the medium privacy setting from
privacy bird and say we'll call that
good so we find that about a third of
the time when I do a search I will get
back at least one site that has a good
p3p policy alright well what if I I
don't like that that medium privacy
setting instead what I really want to
know is the site is not going to share
my personal data without my explicit
consent alright so again it comes up
about a third of the time I find that
okay well what if I don't care about
sharing what I'm worried about is
marketing again about a third of the
time I can find that and so therefore we
came to the conclusion that with privacy
bird today or actually a few months ago
about a third of the time and AOL user
running a typical search would be able
to find a site with a good privacy
policy right we would like this number
to be higher obviously a third of the
time isn't that great but it's enough
that I think we're starting to have a
critical mass of sites that this tool is
beginning to become useful
and have a policy ya know this is a
third of the time when I run a search I
will find at least one site in the top
20 search results nah not that a third
of the search results have it it could
be that they don't have a policy at all
right right yeah so as I said we'd
really like these numbers to be a lot
higher but we're starting to get there
okay how could these numbers get higher
well it turns out that there are a small
number of popular sites that actually
account for a lot of web traffic and a
lot of search results so if Amazon would
adopt p3p ok that would give us an
almost a one-percent boost just just for
Amazon adopting p3p and we're already
getting a boost from US government sites
because US government sites are actually
required to have p3p but only
thirty-nine percent of them do and
actually the military ones are even
worse but this is better than three
years ago when we did a similar study
and we found that only five percent of
them had it so they're catching on
slowly what I think would really boost
adoption though was that if a major
search engine actually offered the
service that would be a big incentive
for websites to adopt p3p ok so now
switching a little to whether this is
actually influencing user behavior so we
have a paper on this that we presented
last week at the soups conference and
there is Sarah's presenting it and we
also had a poster related to it and
Janice and Sarah's are are presenting
their poster there ok so we did an
online shopping study and we we put up
flyers around campus and said you know
get paid to do an online shopping study
and we got 24 students who participated
and we had to make purchases using their
own credit cards because we wanted the
personal information that was at stake
to really be their personal information
and we reimburse them for all the
purchases they made during our study and
we gave him an extra ten dollars for
participating there were three phases
first we had the screening survey we did
a lab experiment
and then we had an exit survey we'll get
to that all right so we started with the
screening survey where we besides
screening them to make sure they were
actually eligible to participate we
wanted to find out up front what were
their privacy concerns and so we got a
lot of data on what their concerns were
and we wanted to match that with what
information privacy finder actually
provides to see whether privacy finder
even addressed the kinds of concerns
that people said they had okay the
laboratory experiment we do not include
people who didn't have minimal privacy
concerns what percentage of the it was a
it was a very small number of people who
are excluded yeah almost I think all but
one of the people who did the screening
survey and we didn't find minimalism so
we asked them about 20 different areas
of privacy and if they said anything
above I don't care we said they have a
minimal privacy concern and I think yeah
there was only one person who just
didn't care about any of these things
okay so we we took the privacy finder
interface and this was the old interface
that had birds not the green boxes and
I'll show it to you again in a minute
and we we took it off the word privacy
and we called it shopping finder so
would be a neutral thing but we told
them that these birds would indicate
about privacy policies we gave him a
little bit of information about that and
half of the students used that interface
and half of the students use the
identical interface but no birds so they
didn't get any privacy information and
we first asked them to purchase on a
typical on household or business item a
surge protector six outlet surge
protector and then we wanted them to
purchase a more privacy sensitive item
so we had them purchase a box of condoms
and we wanted to see whether you know
there was a difference based on the type
of item that was purchased and we said
that if they wanted to they could shift
the items to themselves and keep them or
they could ship them to the lab
so this is what the the interface looked
like that they saw so you can see we've
got the the birds here we did not
reorder the search results here as in
the previous interface so whatever order
they came up that's what they got but we
did hard code it so that everybody would
see the same results because you know if
you do a search and then two hours later
you do the same search you may get
different results okay the median
preference level was also hard coded in
they didn't get to choose their
preference level because those sites did
not have any p3p policies and instead of
putting a yellow bird we just left the
bird off yeah um so this was the the
preference setting that was hard-coded
in so if any of these were violated they
would see a red bird anyone violation
would cause a red bird instead of a
green bird so basically if the site was
collecting health or medical information
and was going to do marketing or share
it if they don't allow an opt-out of
marketing if they're going to share PII
and if they don't have an access
provision those were all things that
could trigger a red bird
ok now we're going to get
let's try that again okay welcome yeah
okay that's where it went to be all
right so these are the products that got
shipped to the lab if people wanted to
keep the surge protectors out now we've
done a subsequent survey which I'm a
cell phone study which I'm not gonna
have time to talk about too much today
and my students chose for that one to
have people buy pens and personal
lubricant and I have stacks of bottles
of personal lubricant sitting in my
office it makes people really wonder
alright so after they did this shopping
experiment we had an exit survey where
we tried to find out from from them what
what went into their decision to make
the purchases at the different websites
we also wanted to find out about what
privacy concerns they had when making
the purchases and we collected
demographic information and then from
the people in the experimental group we
also asked them whether they read the
privacy reports and what understanding
they had about the birds so what do you
think a green bird actually meant okay
so looking at the e-commerce privacy
concern so this was gathered from all
three phases of the study from the
initial screening survey during the
experiment and from the exit survey but
what kept coming up were that people
were concerned about their information
being shared with other companies they
were concerned about unsolicited
marketing especially telemarketing and
they were concerned about not being able
to get off list once they were on them
so a lack of opt out so the this seems
to really be the three big things that
people concerned people have when making
online purchases and we were pleased
that these in fact were concerns that
privacy finder addresses we also saw
that in the condom purchase case there
were some additional concerns that came
up only in that case and that was the
discreet packaging when the item arrives
information about who would have access
to their order history and what kind of
information would actually show up on
their credit card statement these are
things that
that don't really get a dress by privacy
finder the order history sort of gets
addressed but the other two do not okay
so we found that the privacy indicators
do in fact influence purchases so that
that was encouraging and we saw the
biggest impact for the condom purchases
there was a much bigger impact there
than for the power strip purchases
however when we asked people about what
influence their decisions although they
said that the privacy indicator was one
factor price was the biggest factor
although they had no price incentive
because we were going to reimburse them
no matter how much they spent so it was
interesting to see that they still
thought that they should save money even
though we told them they could buy
whatever they wanted and but the amount
of money that we're talking about here
wasn't huge that you know the difference
in price of a box of condoms from one
website to the other is not that that
big a difference in price so we want to
do future studies that are going to
follow up on this price issue so give
them Yeah right bye-bye thinking what
their reward is based on expensive
you've done a certain amount of money
and they must purchase this yeah so
actually again in yeah in the personal
lube study we actually did that yeah mad
and we have more ideas of how to do this
so just just to show you some of the
data so looking at the power strips so
the control group which didn't see any
birds so they had no idea what the
privacy settings were unless they
actually read the privacy policy which
nobody did you can see how that came out
and then the experimental group you can
see that people were much more likely to
actually go to a green bird site we're
actually I shouldn't say much more they
were somewhat more likely it wasn't a
strong statistical finding there yeah
the number is higher my beds um yeah and
I'll get to that in a minute as to why
that is so you can see with the condoms
we had more people looking for green
birds here and although we still have a
number of people who go with no bird and
this was part of the misunderstanding
the birds that a lot of people felt that
what they should be doing is avoiding
Redbirds and that a no bird was going to
be better than a red bird okay we also
asked them about the privacy reports so
we found unfortunately a third of the
papal couldn't actually find the privacy
report you had a click on the bird to
get it so in the our subsequent revision
of the interface we actually have a link
that says privacy report so hopefully
people will be able to find it now and
there were some people who just weren't
interested in reading them they said the
bird symbol was somewhat confusing we
also asked people what do you think a
green bird means and half of them
thought it meant that the site used
encryption okay we never we never even
mentioned the word encryption to them at
any time during the study so that was
just they thought of that and so again
it goes to there there's some
communication that's not going through
one hundred percent okay um so we have a
lot more we want to do in this area we
have submitted grant proposals where
we've outlined a whole series of studies
one of the things we want to do is
better control for a number of the
factors so we want a better control for
price we want to do studies with
multiple purchases where we can have the
same number of good sites and bad sites
across purchases so in this case we had
more sites that had privacy birds at all
with the condom purchase than with the
power strip purchase all right which
made it not entirely comparable so we
want to be able to better control for
these sorts of things we also we gave
them a specific brand of condom but we
didn't give them a specific brand of
power strip and so in the power strip
purchase there are some people who may
have said oh well this one has a 10 foot
cord and this one is a 15 foot cord that
may have been you know a factor we want
to be able to control for that as well
so we learned a lot of things that we
should be able to control for better in
the future we also want to maintain
click log so we can see whether people
are reading privacy policies whether
they're looking at return policies and
what else they might be looking at we'd
actually intended to do that in this
study and there was a bug in our
software that
last minute change introduced and so we
at the end go wait a minute our logs
aren't there yeah another thing that
might be interesting to control for is
whether somebody might purchase this
online or not so for example if I'm it
might be that that if i'm going to buy
condoms i'm only going to go to it right
the store in a part of town that i never
otherwise and so I never would go out
there but then yes I'm going to be very
sensitive in the experiment whereas
anything like we get online I'm not
going to so yeah yeah and and part we'd
like to have a lot more participants and
if we did that then we would be able to
divide it according to whether people
told us they would we did ask them is
this something you've ever bought online
before and things like that but we
didn't have enough participants that we
could even you know analyze the data
that way yeah fine yeah yeah yeah um
that's whether they might you know in
advance give them Alissa screen servant
yep things that you might or might not
right yeah yeah we also actually we want
to do that also because we want to come
up with a list of sensitive things and
we want to find things that make people
uncomfortable but not so uncomfortable
that they refuse to participate in the
study so we were actually worried and
both of these studies that we'd have
people who would come in and when they
found out what they had to purchase
would take their ten dollars and go but
no they all did it they're college
students so I guess so they were willing
to be willing to purchase condoms and
they were willing to purchase organic
raspberry personal lubricant so at least
college students will do that obviously
we'd like to also try this not on
college students as well so so we we do
plan to do a survey where we asked
people about items that might make them
uncomfortable to kind of figure out
whether good items to run these tests on
as well let's see uh yeah we also are
looking at the the problem of the
misleading indicator so in in the last
study that we did we use the green boxes
but our control group instead of having
no indicator they also had green boxes
we just didn't tell them what they meant
and we found that in fact a lot of
people really like the green boxes even
though they had no idea what they meant
which in some ways is kind of depressing
it wasn't it had nothing to do with
privacy it was just as happy green birds
that made them want to go to that site
so we need to drill down on that a bit
more also one look at price sensitivity
and then the final thing we'd like to do
is an experiment in the wild because
even though we're having people use
their real credit cards they're still
not in a normal situation they still may
be purchasing things they don't normally
purchase or in a way that you know
that's not how I would do it and so
they're not in the same kind of mental
state that they would be if they were
really at their own computers and making
purchases so figuring out how to set up
an experiment in the wild is somewhat
difficult but we we are in the process
of trying to set something up with an
ISP that has at least tentatively agreed
to to put the privacy finder interface
on in their system for a fraction of
their customers and then to give us all
the clicks of the search engine for a
two-week period so we'll be able to
compare the search behavior of the
customers who have privacy finder with
the customers who don't have privacy
finder and be able to therefore compare
whether we're seeing different trends as
far as which websites people go to after
conducting searches so that will be
really cool if we can get this data and
we're hoping in the next few months to
have that actually all set up it's
because customers value this oh nothing
so so apparently in in their customer
agreement they have said that they can
experiment on this or is it at will
apparently most isp's do if you read the
fine print of the agreement it turns out
and so they are they're not actually
going to give us any PII they're there
they're going to they're just going to
give us the clicks with a student's
anonymous identifier
in the data for the PII he was innocent
I'm with services no I come or permit
the business I yeah I said most isp's do
this yeah yeah yeah so you know so we
will have data that won't have any
personal information in it and the the
customers are going to see oh there's
some new icons on my screen now what
thing I don't know is because it's a
random group of customers who are going
to see this you know if their neighbor
like has the same ISP but it doesn't see
it you know they're good hey hey I got
these new green boxes they go what green
boxes I that I don't know but they claim
they do these studies all the time and
it works and so we shall see but it I
see it as kind of a unique opportunity
to get this kind of in the wild data
just to see whether it's actually
influence that all you each time I go in
sometimes you go in and get totally
different a few minutes later you get a
totally different site so there it's not
just the ISPs I mean see a lot of
experiments yeah I know Amazon does this
a lot also all right and I think that
yeah that's it hey Gloria yeah do you
have any feeling for how many of you all
sites for your search terms and so forth
are in the EU because the EU does not
the same pressure for privacy policies
because you gotta do a fan for reading
level default anyway well so actually in
the EU they're required to have privacy
policies but there's no pressure for p3p
because part of the the EU legislation
says that you have to provide people
with with notice about the data that
you're collecting so this requires
websites to have privacy policies but
they don't necessarily label as such and
in some cases instead of having one
policy at the point where the data is
collected they'll say okay here we're
collecting this information is what
we're going to do with it and then some
other part of the site they'll do
something else but they have something
like a privacy policy they don't
necessarily have any incentive though to
have p3p and one of the things that that
we're going to be doing since some of
the sites that come up in english
language search terms are not in the US
so we have those sites in our database
and we do plan to do some analysis by by
country it and we don't know one hundred
percent because now.com is used all over
the world but if there is a country code
we can definitely analyze that and we
also want to break it down more by
industry sector so we want to get lists
of companies in certain sectors and then
run our database against those lists in
order to see are there particular
sectors within ecommerce that are that
have more p 3 p or less p 3 p and
whatnot yeah jurisdiction define is that
where the services hosted or where the
business is incorporated or all enough
so you can't even use the IP or anything
to try to really figure out where the
jurisdiction yeah I mean we can use it
as a proxy yeah take it ready you have
to give us a general idea but yeah and
there are companies that are
multinational that haven't had different
privacy policies depending on which
website you going to so that'll actually
has at 25 p 3 p policies for each of the
depending room yeah so when when you go
so if you look at the English privacy
policy on the dell website i haven't
looked at in a while but last time i
looked you click on the privacy policy
link and it says what country do you
live in and it gives you a list of like
25 different countries and you pick that
one there's an enormous set of URLs and
presumably not every web page has linked
to a privacy policy I'm the privacy
policy from the URL um most big
companies have it set up so that every
web page does have a link to the privacy
policy they put it in the standard
footer on the big companies tend to do
that
there may be some very practical ways to
do something with lots and wear them
privacy flying or maybe favor okay great
yeah so the Indian in the Watson you're
going to do what is the house guy's ego
to expose the interface to the user it's
not just wishing gathering data they
have to somehow let me go to give a plug
in or so when people do a search using
the search engine on the ISP site as
opposed to going to Google but if you
just use the so you know if you imagine
it with MSM if you used msn search then
for those users you get the extra
privacy annotation search hopefully when
we write the paper and you'll be able to
find out who it is I mentioned this
before that I'm I'm very concerned about
the two distinct and contradictory
methods of presenting the positive news
leader yeah and this seems crucial
because they actually contradict each
other well but most users are not going
to see both okay but the scene both no
no no no so when we run the study we
don't actually give them a rough that
has privacy bird in it we're just having
to do the search engine so yeah yeah so
so privacy bird is you know it's a free
download and it's been downloaded by
like 50,000 people in the entire world
so but most people I mean that's a lot
of people but it's not a lot of people
right so so yeah most people won't won't
see both yeah are your studies going to
focus on which method is better yeah so
one of the things we want to do is is
look at the icon and another thing we
want to look at is the idea of putting
the icon in the browser versus in the
search engine we think it's better in
the search engine for when you're
searching then they have it in the
browser but we'd like to actually test
that in the study as well
if
thank you